[موسيقى]
اسمي سارة آسف وأنا
صانع محتوى مصري مرحبًا بك
رسميًا في قناتي على اليوتيوب ،
نحن الآن في هوائي ،
وهو أحد الأماكن المفضلة لدي في
مصر واسمحوا لي أن أوضح لكم لماذا وهي حقًا
واحدة من  أقدم الأسواق وهي
حرفياً في الجزء الذي أصفف فيه ، لذا فإن
مجوهراتي المفضلة هي من الجوع لأكون
صادقًا ، سأبحث عنك في أحد
الأماكن المفضلة لدي لتناول الطعام دوليًا والذي
يُطلق عليه مجتمع حسين ، كلما
تيسر لي هذا هو واحد من أوائل  الأماكن التي
أتيت إليها ، هذا هو الطعام هنا ، إنه
نوع مذهل مثل البيتزا ولكن ميكانيكيًا ليس
بالفعل
[الموسيقى]
حيويًا للغاية ، ستجد
أصحاب المتاجر يتصلون بك وستجد
الأشخاص الذين يدعونك 14 هو إعادة التشغيل. أنا
أحب الأشخاص الموجودين هنا  من المحتمل أن يكون
الشيء المفضل لدي في الشهرة على
التلفزيون لأنني عشت في الخارج طوال حياتي
، أردت حقًا أن أجد
نفسي وأجد ما هو في المنزل وأشعر بأنني
نوع من Heloise حيث وجدت
حقًا كل شيء في مصر في مكان واحد
[Mus  ic]